- All right, good afternoon everyone.
My name is Jake Burns.
Today we're gonna talk about migrations.
So this stat is interesting
because it hasn't changed
much in the past few years.
Cloud computing generates
over 100 billion in annual revenue,
yet still 85% of the global
IT spend is still on premises.
So the question is why?
And it's been my observation
that this is not a choice,
most organizations want
to be in the cloud.
It's just that most of the
ones that I've worked with,
they're not having an easy go at it.
They're struggling in some way.
And so I've spent
probably the last 10 years
analyzing this in some shape or form,
either migrating personally
or talking to and advising
executives on how to do it.
And in the past 12 months,
really focusing on this,
like, why is this the case?
Why is migrating so difficult?
And so I'm going to attempt
to answer that here.
and I'm gonna try to leave
a lot of time at the end
for Q&A, because some of
the things I talk about,
it starts off very simple,
but a lot of it can be counterintuitive,
so I wanna give you an
opportunity to ask me questions.
So I have a very interesting
role here at AWS.
I'm part of the Executives
in Residence team.
We're a team that's comprised
of former CIOs and CTOs
and other senior leaders
who have all led large
scale transformations
using AWS cloud in our prior roles.
So we've been on the customer side
and we've all successfully
led a transformation.
And so on top of that, we have
a lot of these conversations
with senior leaders across
all industries globally
on various topics, but
I tend to talk about
the ones who wanna talk about migration,
I get to talk to those.
So I've had hundreds
of those conversations
in the last seven years.
And so I've got to see the
good, the bad, and the ugly.
So before this, I was with
Live Nation/Ticketmaster
and I led a all-in migration to AWS.
Now I had a 12 month deadline.
Largely legacy systems,
things that were not born in the cloud,
not meant to be run in the cloud,
no budget and frozen head count.
And the team that I had at the time
had no experience with the cloud.
And cloud wasn't really cool at the time.
It was back in 2015,
it was the stone age
when it comes to cloud.
Now we didn't do it in
12 months, we did in 17,
but we were able to get some
impressive metrics out of it.
So impressive that we still talk about
this migration a decade later,
reduced our total cost of ownership
by nearly half after optimization.
Before optimization, it was about 18%.
So that's a result of having no budget.
It's either do it cost neutral or fail,
and we weren't willing to fail.
Our availability got better,
our resiliency got better.
All of our performance
issues got resolved.
And so a lot of the questions I get
are like, how did you do that?
Well, the cloud, I think
most people know by now,
is very elastic,
and so it's very easy
to find the bottlenecks.
So the key is really
matching your capacity
and your utilization
so you can reduce your costs
while reducing or eliminating
your performance bottle
necks at the same time.
That's basically the key.
Now, there's six things
that I've identified
because I've looked at a lot
of migrations since then.
What's different between the
experience that I went through
and the experience that I
see on a almost daily basis.
And I hear from customers
on a almost daily basis.
And to be clear, some
of them are successful,
but not all of them are.
And it's my goal to make
all of them successful.
So what are the successful
ones have in common?
Well, I've identified these six pillars.
First is they have a compelling why.
Now, this can't be because
we wanna save money
or because the CEO said so.
It has to be something that the people
who you're depending on,
hopefully your own employees,
are going to really care about.
This should be your company's mission.
This should be, you know,
something that drives them.
Because when things get hard,
they're gonna need to be
able to push through that.
Two is utilize constraints,
and this is one that
could be counterintuitive.
You know, when people hear about my story,
you know, 12 month deadline,
no budget, frozen headcount,
and then still was able to be successful,
I sometimes say "That's
why we were successful."
A lot of the migrations that I see fail
are the ones that have too many resources,
and we'll get into that
a little bit more later.
Third is the invest in people,
and this one should be a no brainer.
The more skilled your
workforce is in cloud,
the better they're gonna be
at migrating to the cloud
and at operating in the cloud.
And so the investment is completely key.
Building momentum in a
migration or any transformation,
and a lot of this applies to
AI transformations as well,
it's super key because things
tend to start off slow,
and then as you start
winning that compounds.
And inertia can compound as well,
you could just keep going slow as well.
Embracing simplicity is is the next one.
And I would say this is probably
the biggest one that I see violated.
I see, excess complexity in
my opinion, is the root cause
of failed migrations and failed
transformations in general.
And so what this means is most
of the things that people do
when they migrate are
simply not necessary.
Or the ones that are necessary,
they're far too complex.
And last but not least,
and this is a hard requirement,
is having strong leadership.
You have to have somebody
who's accountable,
and they have to be, have
the authority to do things
and it doesn't have to
be a lot of authority,
but they need to be accountable
for those things that
they have authority for,
and they need to have
a little bit of guts.
So for past seven years, like I said,
I've been talking to
hundreds of executive teams
on the topic of migration
and I hear the same objections
over and over again.
So Live Nation/Ticketmaster,
we were, Live Nation is an
entertainment company, right?
So I'll talk to an energy company,
they'll say, "Well that would never work
for an energy company," right?
So we're special, right?
Or the scope is too big.
So we migrated, you know,
we're $11 billion revenue
runway business at the time,
much more today, but there are companies
that are much bigger than that
and they can very easily say
it would never work at our scale.
And the third most common,
it's almost always these three,
is that we have unique
regulatory requirements.
So like the cloud won't work for us,
or it's hard for us to migrate
that quickly because of that.
But the thing is, when you strip away
all the assumptions and complexity,
cloud migration is really simple.
It's really moving your
applications and data
from one place to another,
sometimes it's a virtualized environment
in your data center,
to a virtualized environment in the cloud.
And yes, maybe it's a
different technology,
but most of us who are
doing cloud migrations,
we've done data center
consolidations in the past,
it's very similar.
It doesn't have to be that much different.
So I could say this with
confidence because I've done it,
but I could say it even
more with confidence now
because I've helped so
many others do it as well.
It really is the simple.
Now there are workloads that
are difficult to migrate,
you know, mainframes for example,
that require full refactor.
But those are unique edge cases.
Those are not the most common.
So a more generalized
approach is a better approach.
Let's manage the exceptions as exceptions.
And let's take the complexity
out of the 99% that could be easy.
So a good migration
framework is universal.
It'll work in every industry
because your servers don't care
what industry your business is in.
It's effective at any scale
because a good framework,
any good framework is
a scalable one, right?
You take something that
works and you scale it up.
And this has been proven with
this methodology as well.
And it should have compliance built in,
a good framework should
not violate compliance,
it should be flexible
enough to handle compliance.
So there's some lessons that I've learned
through this process,
and some of them can be a
little bit counterintuitive.
This is one of them.
You're more likely to fail
from too few constraints
than from too many.
This is one that people find surprising.
It's like, "Wait a minute,
you're gonna take resources away from me
and I'm gonna be more successful."
Yes, that's usually the case.
Most cloud migrations are overfunded
and their deadlines are
way too long in the future.
I had a 12 month deadline,
it took me 17 months.
If I had a 17 month deadline,
I think it would've taken me two years.
If you gave me two years,
maybe it never would've
get done at all, right?
So some of you may be
familiar with Parkinson's Law.
Basically it explains why, in college,
when your homework is due,
you do it, you start it
the night before instead of like a week
when it was assigned.
We typically have too much time
and too many resources do things.
Now you can take this too far,
but work will expand to fill
up that time that you have.
So if you give yourself five
years to do a migration,
it's going to take five years minimum.
Nobody sets out to do
a five year migration
and it takes two years, right?
But you could set out to
do a one year migration,
it take a year and a half,
that's a much more common pattern.
So what this does is when you set
these seemingly unrealistic goals,
it gives you a sense of urgency.
And if you don't have
that sense of urgency,
if you have too much time,
you never get started.
If you have too much time,
say you have a hundred things to do,
most of us, we're gonna
pick out of that hundred,
which one to attack first,
the easiest one, right?
Let's just take the easy one off the list.
But if you had to pick
only 10, you're gonna pick
one of the most top 10 impactful ones.
And that's what the sense of
urgency does, the constraint,
it forces you to focus on what matters.
And innovation, why innovate
if you don't have to?
As human beings, we're lazy.
This isn't a bad thing,
it's efficiency, right?
So if it's worked for us in the past,
it's probably gonna work
for us in the future.
So if we've been doing
migrations like this
for this amount of time, why
not keep doing it that way?
Well, the reason is because we can't.
And constraint forces that.
So you're more likely to
succeed with constraints
than you are without.
This is one of my conclusions.
And nobody wants their
budget taken away from them.
Nobody wants to be under
an unrealistic deadline.
But you can, this is where
the innovation comes from
and this is where the
efficiency comes from,
and it makes for a much
more interesting story
when the odds are stacked against you
and you succeed anyway,
and you'd be surprised.
So instead you put
constraints into motion,
and then you find a way.
So a deadline forces you to find a way.
So for me, I had to begin
before I felt ready.
This is something that I was told,
begin before you feel ready, right?
So I was given the mandate
to migrate in December.
I started beginning of January, why?
Because I had 12 months.
I'm not gonna waste any days, right?
I had to focus on what mattered.
I couldn't get distracted by things
and had to work backwards from a goal.
All right, so it's
easy, 12 month deadline,
we're gonna be done by Christmas
and work backwards from there.
So a budget, and more
specifically a budget
that's smaller than you
would like it to be,
forces you to become lean,
forces you to invent and
simplify, as we say at AWS.
You have to find a new way of doing things
because the old way,
we just don't have the
money to do it anymore.
And that's where new things get invented.
And in my case, a limited
headcount, what it did,
it forced me to motivate my existing team.
So I talked about in the beginning
how I had a frozen headcount, no budget.
So I couldn't hire cloud experts
to come in and do the migration.
So I had to develop a skill.
In order to be successful,
I had to develop the skill
of motivating my team, getting
them upskilled very quickly
and enabling them to be successful.
Now, it's not an easy thing to do.
I'll give you the playbook
and I'll answer your questions
and I'll tell you exactly how to do it.
But once you do that, it is
like having a superpower.
When you can take people
who don't have the skill that you need,
and this is applicable
to AI right now too,
everybody's looking for AI talent.
Good luck hiring those people,
they're in high demand.
But you could take the people you have
and if you can get them interested in it
and you can get them able to learn it,
and then you can get them able to use it
and in a meaningful way
within your organization,
you could have an endless
pipeline of talent.
And that is, as a leader,
it's one of the most liberating
feelings you can have.
So one of the other things that I see,
I would say anti-pattern is conflating,
and this one's a little controversial,
conflating migration and modernization.
The way I look at it is this, migrating,
if people are having a hard time migrating
and people are having a
hard time modernizing,
if you combine both of them,
it's like complexity times complexity.
So your odds of success go down.
And then the common objection
is, "Well, a lift and
shift gives you no value."
Well first of all, I'd argue that,
because your data's in the cloud
and you can use that for AI workloads
and you can do other things as well.
But I'll largely agree with that.
But I'll also say that you
are more likely to migrate
or modernize more quickly,
like your apps will be more modern
and a date sooner than they would be,
if you were to migrate then modernize,
separate them, decouple them.
Separate the complexity
into different stages.
Your modernization will be done sooner
than if you try to do them
both at the same time.
So migrate so you can modernize sooner.
So you can be in the cloud
and you can use all the
great cloud services.
So this is a quote, this
is me from way long ago.
"I don't hire cloud
engineers, I build them."
This is what I would say because
that's how I felt about it.
I was building, it's kind
of a weird way to say it,
but I was building a
pipeline of cloud engineers.
I didn't hire a single
cloud engineer, ever.
I created them out of
people who had IT skills,
but they didn't have cloud talent.
I think we could do this with
AI as well, with any skill.
If they have competency and motivation,
you can build a pipeline
from existing employees.
And so this is the
strategy that I recommend.
Insource your cloud transformation.
If you outsource it, which is
the default that people do,
it's going to be seen as a threat.
And why wouldn't it, right?
'Cause you're basically telling your team
that you have no confidence
that they could do it.
We're bringing in others to do it for you.
It also has a problem
of these people who you bring in to do it,
you're training them and
giving them experience
and then they take that knowledge
with them when they leave.
So in my experience, in my opinion,
they should be paying
you for that experience.
That experience is very valuable.
So you're robbing your
team of that experience.
And then it also incentivizes
short-term thinking.
Because if you think about it,
if you have some hired guns that come in
and they build it and they're gonna leave
and they don't have to maintain it,
they might cut some corners, right?
But if you know you're
gonna build something
and you know you're gonna
have to maintain it,
you're more likely to do it in a way
that is gonna be, have higher
operational excellence,
let's put it that way.
So my thought process here
is insource the migration,
let your own team do it.
You know, you're gonna
bring in external help.
Partners are an excellent resource
and AWS itself is an excellent resource,
and you should bring them in,
but their goal should
be to become irrelevant.
Their goal should be
to upskill your people
because your people are the ones
who are gonna have to
maintain this, right?
And so in DevOps, you say
"You build it, you run it."
I think that should be true
for just about everything, right?
You build it, you run it
with the cloud as well.
Bring in the experts to
transfer the knowledge.
Bring in lower cost resources
to kind of free up their plate
so they can work on it and
do your best as a leader
to allow them to focus on it.
So it has a lot of
advantages when you do this.
Just being purely selfish.
The people that work for you,
or the, all the people
in your organization,
they already know each other.
They already know how
to work with each other.
When you bring in new
people, there's onboarding
and there's complexity with that.
They know how your organization works.
Every organization has bureaucracy, right?
The way of doing things, that's a delay.
Think about it, if you have
to onboard a bunch of people
in the beginning of a
migration, then learning how
just to navigate your organization
is extra time that it's gonna take.
And not having to hire them is great.
The fact that they already work for you
makes it a lot easier.
So if, even just being purely selfish,
'cause a lot of times it
sounds like I'm saying
invest in your employees as like charity.
No, I'm saying do it for selfish reasons.
It's gonna make your
migration more successful
and you're gonna be able to operate it
more successfully in the long term
and it's gonna make your life easier.
So it's easier to teach your cloud skills
to your existing workforce
than how your organization
works to external people.
That's the key point there, right?
And if you think about
that, it makes total sense.
Cloud skills are a relatively
easy thing to learn,
especially if you're giving
them opportunity to use it,
which you should be doing,
learning how your organization works?
For some organizations, this
could be very difficult.
Okay, so I'm making this
sound so easy, right?
There are some problems, but
I'll give you some solutions.
So the first problem is,
yeah, they're too busy, right?
Every single time when you say
"We're gonna let you do the migration,"
they say, "We're too busy."
They're telling you the truth, right?
So my answer to that is, well
what are you so busy doing
that you can't do a cloud
migration or cloud adoption
or building this new app in the cloud
or whatever the case may be.
Whatever that answer is,
outsource that, that's undifferentiated.
That's stuff that you can
outsource at low cost.
That's just keeping the lights on.
Free up their time and
they'll appreciate it.
Now the next one, they're
much less likely to vocalize,
but it's typically true, they're fearful.
What are they fearful of?
They're fearful of the unknown.
They're fearful "If I do
this, can I even do this?
Am I gonna succeed?
I've never done it before."
For most people, when
they do a cloud migration,
it's their first time doing it.
So it's natural to be fearful.
They're fearful "Will I have the skills
to maintain this new cloud environment.
Am I engineering myself out of a job?"
There's a lot of things that
they have to be fearful of.
So we need to address that.
So give them a safety net, right?
They might not vocalize it,
but they need the safety net.
So give them training, lots of training,
with a goal, right?
They need to know going into the training
that they're gonna be the
ones that are gonna drive,
bring in experts, AWS
Solutions architects,
professional services
partners, all these people
who can help them and guide
them in the beginning.
And you know, you really just
need to get buy in from them.
And this kind of speaks to the last point.
They may not even care, right?
So we need to get them to care.
If you're the boss and they work for you,
they may like, want you to be successful,
but I think if they have ownership of it,
they're gonna be a little bit more,
let's say receptive.
So outsourcing to enable,
solve those first two problems,
too busy and fearful.
So let's talk about how
we solve this last one
of them not caring.
'Cause outsourcing itself
is rarely the problem,
it's what we choose to
outsource that's the problem.
We outsource the fun
stuff, the cloud migration,
the building of the
new agenetic AI system.
We're outsourcing that to people
because we see the skills
gap in our organization.
We should let our employees do that
and we should outsource the boring stuff
they don't want to do to make time for it.
So how do we get buy-in?
Because that's really what
we're talking about here.
Well, I talked about a compelling why.
You have to have a compelling why.
It has to be something
they actually care about
and it should be related to your industry.
What does your company do?
What does your organization do?
Most leaders have this
advantage and they don't use it
because they just don't know
how to articulate it, right?
So for a live entertainment company,
it might be we're making the
fan experience better, right?
We're gonna make it easier to buy tickets.
And we're going to make,
when you go to a concert,
you know, we're gonna have
this interactive experience.
All these things that the cloud
will legitimately enable you to do, right?
Just you have to tell that story
because when they're asked
what they're doing at work,
what are they gonna say?
Right, "Well, I'm doing
stuff in the cloud,"
or, you know, "I'm doing IT stuff."
Let them tell a, you know, a good story.
So there's a, speaking of
stories, there's a story of JFK
going to visit the NASA
space center in 1962, right?
And he encountered janitor
and asked him, "What do you do here?"
Right, and the janitor said,
"I'm putting a man on the moon," right?
And this is the kind of
mentality you have to think of.
The janitor was not telling a lie.
He's helping put a man on the moon.
He had a part to play in this.
Everybody has a part to play
in the mission of the organization.
And when you instill
that mentality in them,
then they will be enthusiastic,
at least that's part of it.
That's one of three parts of it.
Second is sharing the how, right?
You'd be surprised how many leaders
keep their plans a secret.
If you don't share your plan,
then your team might just
assume you don't have a plan
and you might not actually have a plan,
so this will force you to create one.
But the other thing you need
to do is solicit feedback.
Allow them to, look,
it's not a free for all,
but like if you have a
better idea, tell me, right?
We have what we call tenants at Amazon
and it always says, you know,
these are kind of like principles,
leadership principles for
like projects and teams.
It always says, "Unless
you know better ones,"
these are our tenants
unless you know better ones.
And every single time it says,
unless you know better ones,
that should be the mantra.
Like, here's the plan,
unless you got a better one.
This is my idea how to do it
unless you have a better one.
So listen to them, right?
Now, even if you don't
incorporate all of their feedback,
just the fact that you're asking for it
creates a sense of ownership.
And the fact that you're
sharing what you're gonna do
gives them confidence that
it actually can be done,
'cause like I could see the plan,
I could see how this could be done,
versus we're going to the
cloud and how we're gonna do it
is a just big question mark, right?
So make it our plan, right?
They might care about your plan,
they're gonna care about
our plan, their plan.
And then finally what's in it for them.
And this is I think an easy one with cloud
because you know, with the
cloud you, like I said,
you could transform people's careers
and you know, I like to reframe
we're engineering ourself
out of a job into,
we're engineering ourselves
into a better job.
And this is the truth,
it's just a reframe, right?
And so when they understand that,
when they understand that, you know,
if you're the type of organization
that's gonna give them training,
get them certifications,
allow them to actually be
hands-on and do the work.
That's rare.
And you happen to work
for a company like this,
at the end of this,
you're not gonna care about job security.
I'm gonna be fighting to keep you, right?
And you should ask me for a raise.
Doesn't mean I can give you one,
but you should definitely
ask for one, right?
I wasn't able to give many,
but I encourage them to ask.
So these are the three ingredients,
and you can use this not
just with your employees,
but with your peers and
with your management,
whoever you need to get buy-in from
for transformative change.
So then you upskill.
But the upskilling, there's
some very specific things
that I recommend you do with upskilling.
First you have to have buy-in,
which you just talked about.
Because if they don't care,
then like, it's just a paid vacation,
you send them to training, right?
Get the timing right, do
the training, like for me,
I had to do the training while
I was doing the migration.
So I actually had to get
so much buy-in from my team
that they were willing to do
three jobs at once, right?
Training in the morning,
migration in the afternoon,
and in your free time,
just try to keep the
business running, right?
So that was a lot to ask.
Now you don't necessarily have
to do 'em at the same time,
but the next best thing
is to do the training
immediately before the migration.
Any interval that you have in between
that knowledge tends to get forgotten.
So putting it into practice
as quickly as possible is super important.
And there's the other things here as well.
Use all available means.
AWS has a lot of free resources
that we can give you for training.
Solutions architects,
you know, our partners.
There's a lot of people who will come in
and help you get upskilled
and don't ever stop doing it.
It's a continuous process.
So now you may have to hire
after you've given everyone
in your organization
a chance to fill new roles in
the cloud, you may need to,
but please give everyone a chance first,
this is super important.
Now you may have gaps,
hire for those gaps.
Now it's gonna be hard to
find people who are qualified.
So you may need to do a couple things
like adjusting your requirements.
One thing I've found that
works here is everyone,
has anyone here noticed
how many agenetic AI engineer
job postings there are?
And they all want like
three years experience,
five years experience.
It's like, yeah, this technology
hasn't been around that long, right?
So hire people who are motivated,
hire people who want to learn.
That is a higher indicator of
success than existing skills.
Now, existing skills is a
good base to have, of course,
but do you wanna pay a premium for that?
So this is kind of a cheat code.
Get people who are early in their career
but are sharp and smart and want to learn.
Or maybe they're later in their career
and they just don't have,
they give a solid technical foundation,
they just don't understand cloud
and no one's giving them a chance, right?
These people you can get for,
it's an incredible deal, let's
just put it that way, right?
And you upskill them and
then you have those people,
you have that pipeline
I was talking about.
And lastly, you have to
become an organization
that top talent, that attracts
top performers, right?
You may have heard the quote,
"Become the person that
attracts success," right?
It's kinda a similar thing.
Like are you the type of organization
that top performers wanna work at?
You know, top performers
wanna work with other top performers.
They wanna work on interesting problems,
they wanna be hands-on.
They don't wanna work for an organization
that just outsources the fun work, right?
They wanna work for an organization
that's gonna allow them to
become more valuable over time
through hands-on experience,
through training and all those things.
So become that type of organization.
Work on interesting stuff
and like as a leader,
care about making your team more valuable.
I'd much rather have the problem
of retaining valuable people
than the problem of having
people who are not valuable
or can't do the work, right?
So you don't get to choose
whether you have a problem,
you just get to choose which
of those problems you have.
So talent's something
your organization attracts
by what it becomes.
Spend less time on recruiting
and more time on becoming
that type of organization.
Think of like the top five
companies in the world.
They don't have to do a
lot of recruiting, right?
They have to do, recruiting for them
is sorting through all the
resumes that gets sent to them.
So be attractive to top performers
and the talent will come
to you that will help.
All of these help a little bit,
none of it's gonna get
you all the way there.
Okay, so another anti-pattern,
elaborate committees and org structures.
I don't think that this helps very much.
So I advocate for a very,
very simple structure.
And it's three parts and
it's very easy to set up.
First is your cloud team,
they're the people that do the migration.
You can call them whatever you want.
I call them the cloud team.
They're usually infrastructure.
In my case, they're a
former infrastructure team,
I rebranded cloud services.
This could be DevOps folks,
but these are the people who
are gonna do it, hands on.
You got an advisory board,
I like to call it minimal viable, CCOE,
minimal viable cloud center of excellence,
very lightweight, very informal.
You got finance, you got HR,
InfoSec, you got, you know,
one person, one leader from each of those.
Just to agree on, you know, policies
and how we're gonna do
things, but not to micromanage
and it shouldn't take very long to set up.
And then stakeholders,
which are everyone else in
the organization, right?
These are who you serve as the cloud team.
So these are application
owners or business unit owners.
If there's no application owner, right?
Typically it's application
owners, it's app folks.
So yes, infrastructure people
have to answer to that,
people just like always,
unfortunately for the
infrastructure folks.
But, now the app people
have to answer to business,
So it all ends up kind of
working out in the end.
But this is a very simple structure
and this is really all you
need, this is all I used,
and this works at any scale.
And this could be set up in a day, really,
it's not that difficult to do.
Now the stakeholders, you're gonna ask
as little from them as possible,
and we're gonna give
them as much as possible.
So all we're gonna ask for them
is agree to this cutover date,
agree to this cloud architecture,
if you even care about
how we architect it,
and just give us permission
to migrate it to the cloud.
And then do just however much testing
you think you need to do at the end of it
to ensure that it works.
And it's gonna work, because
as you'll see in a minute,
we're not gonna make very many changes
in the migration phase.
Kind of alluded to this earlier.
Another benefit of doing it that way
is that the migration tends to work.
The migrations tend to not
have to be migrated back
because we make very little changes.
Okay, so create a meritocracy.
Now what I found is that
within the cloud team,
your team members fall into
one of three categories.
This is usually the smallest category,
it's the early adopters.
These should be your new leaders.
These are people who are
enthusiastic about the cloud.
And they may not be your
senior level people.
They may be, but they may not be.
You know, in my case, one of
'em was very senior level,
one of them wasn't.
But put them in leadership positions
that enable them, right?
They're gonna be the ones that prove
that this could be done to everyone else.
You got the passive majority, right?
So obviously that's the
most amount of people.
'cause it's got majority
right in the name.
But they're usually just gonna
go which way the wind blows
if we're being honest, right?
If this thing looks like
it's gonna be successful,
I'm gonna support it.
If it looks like it's gonna fail,
then I'm gonna have no part of it, right?
So they need to be won over,
which means we have to
start winning quickly.
And that's, as you'll see in
a minute, part of the strategy
is we've gotta start winning very quickly.
And then you got active resistors.
And most organizations have these, right?
And thing is don't fight them.
My suggestion is embrace that.
Because think about
it, the early adopters,
and to some extent the passive majority,
they're the ones who are
complaining, "We're too busy,"
Okay, the resistors,
the ones we lovingly call server huggers,
(audience laughs)
in cloud migration industry.
You know, let them manage the servers,
let them keep the lights on,
let them do, someone has to do it.
Let them manage the outsource team
that's doing the quote
unquote boring work.
They love doing that kind of work.
They will come around eventually.
So other things you can do
here within this meritocracy
is create new career ladders.
You know, I did something funny.
You know, you have your technical track,
your manager track, and
then added a cloud track.
And you know, it sends a clear message
when the cloud track actually has
more rungs on the ladder
than the other two tracks.
So create incentives, right?
You want to get promoted,
you want to get a higher
level in this organization,
this is the path to do it.
Give opportunity to
everyone equally, right?
So one of the things that's gonna happen
is people are gonna complain.
They're gonna say, "How come that person
gets to be on the cloud team and I don't?"
So the way you get around that is you say,
"Okay, cloud team, you
get to set the rules
of who's on the cloud team," right?
And now you live with your own rules.
So we're trying to make
this as fair as possible.
Again, not to be charitable,
but because it works.
When you create a meritocratic system,
you get better results.
Because what ends up
happening is the results,
however you define them,
those who produce more of them
get more responsibility, right?
And those who get less.
So it creates incentive
structures that work
and it also gets the
right people involved.
And then be transparent
about all of this, right?
Let them own it, and there's
no hidden qualifications.
All the qualifications are there.
And I don't care if you're
the most senior engineer
on the team, you still have
to get that certification
if you wanna be a senior
cloud engineer, you know,
if that's the rule that you make.
And I don't care if you're
just a lowest person
on the ladder, if you're
a help desk person
taking tier one tickets, if
you can get that certification,
you could be a senior engineer, right?
So create these rules.
Let the cloud team own it
and apply it to everybody.
All right, so now we're gonna cram
a bunch of more information
in the end here,
'cause this is where it gets a little bit
more into the mechanics of it, right?
How do we actually migrate?
I've been talking about
culture this whole time, right?
Well, 90% of the problems are culture.
But let me give you some tips
on the actual migration mechanics,
'cause this was a little unique
how we got this done so quickly.
And I've been able to replicate this
with other organizations
that I've worked with.
And so it is universal.
I do believe it works any size
organization in any industry,
and feel free to challenge me on that.
Hopefully we have Q&A at the end.
So I'll let you challenge
me in front of everyone.
So what we wanna do is focus on the goal.
We don't wanna get distracted.
We're gonna eliminate all the complexity,
all the things that have
nothing to do with migration,
we're not gonna do them.
And the things that are necessary,
but maybe don't make the
migration happen quickly,
we're going to simplify
it as much as possible.
So we're going to embrace
this minimal viable framework, right?
So we have minimal viable committees,
like I talked about before.
We have minimal viable migration plan,
which we're gonna talk about now.
I suggest creating a
minimal viable landing zone,
which is again, kind of
controversial, it should take days,
weeks, maybe, at most to
create a landing zone.
This is what we call a two-way
door decision at Amazon.
It's a reversible decision.
Your landing zone can evolve.
It doesn't have to be perfect
for you to start migrating.
So that should be done quickly as well.
And then finally, my favorite
minimal viable refactoring,
because that completely
gets rid of the 7Rs.
And I'm gonna go through that quickly.
So we wanna make the process
loosely coupled and non-blocking.
And if you're an engineer,
you know what that means.
It means one thing does
not block the other,
and each, it's almost like a
microservices architecture.
And that's how if you put an engineer
in charge of a cloud
migration, that's what you get.
And it worked for us, so
let's go over it in detail.
So here's the minimal
viable migration plan.
You first identify all
the in-scope applications,
then you identify an
owner for each of them.
Then you map the infrastructure
that belongs to each one of those,
so you know what
infrastructure to migrate.
You map the dependencies, if any.
And in my experience, there's far fewer
than what most people think.
We're going to determine the sequence
and there's a formula for that
that's really, really easy.
And then we're gonna create cutover dates
and we'll just work
backwards from the deadline
because we're gonna have a deadline.
So here are applications or
mock applications, right?
We're gonna just go over a
very simple example here.
These are our applications.
We're going to order them
from easiest to migrate
and least business critical
and most stakeholder support.
Those three dimensions are gonna go first
and then the most difficult to migrate
that are most business critical
and have the least stakeholder support.
Remember, stakeholders are
our application owners,
so they're the ones we have to satisfy.
We're gonna put them towards the end.
Now the idea is that we want
to get some quick wins here.
'cause we've gotta win that
passive majority, right?
So now we're gonna turn
that into a migration plan
and we can only be sure of two dates.
The first one, which is immediately,
and the last one, which is the deadline,
so that's quite easy.
So here's why I do it this way.
The importance of momentum.
You find when you talk to people
who've done successful transformations
or migrations, it's always
this very happy story.
And the story is that everybody
was a supporter from the beginning.
Everybody helped plan it,
everybody was a sponsor, right?
'Cause it's survivorship bias.
You're talking to the
successful ones, right?
You don't talk to the people
who did failing migrations.
There's no owners of those, right?
So how do we do this?
The problem is, in the beginning
you haven't done anything,
so why should anyone in your
organization support you?
Well, the way you break the cycle,
the way you get it started
is you start with a small,
very small, maybe like comically small,
like a single web server,
and then you build off of that.
You build a series of
wins, like once, twice.
You know, what is it like once
is, twice is a coincidence,
three times is a pattern.
You know, at some point it's like,
okay, this thing is successful
and you start getting people on board
and you make a lot of noise
each step of the way, right?
Say we just migrated like
a simple file server.
I'll throw a party over
that in the beginning.
I want everyone in the
organization to know,
I want those passive majority
to know that this is working
so that they come on board
so that it becomes this kind
of self-fulfilling prophecy.
Which by the way, can
go in reverse if you do,
if you have some disasters
in the beginning,
so we have to avoid that.
And then, yes, here's the quip, right?
So you get all the support
you need after you need it.
That's the thing at the end,
you have a perfect migration plan
and everyone's a supporter
of your migration.
But in the beginning, what
most people don't see,
and maybe some of you in this
room are in this situation,
you're usually all by yourself.
You usually don't have a lot
of support in the beginning.
My suggestion, once you're successful
is let them take credit for it, right?
It doesn't matter you won.
All right, migration planning credit,
so a minimal viable landing zone.
Not gonna spend a lot of
time on this except to say
that I could fit everything
you need in the landing zone
on one slide with room to spare.
So do it quickly.
You can add to it, you do
not need every single feature
that landing zone offers.
You can use the ones you like,
you can spend as much time
or as little time on it as you
want, but it's not migrating.
So I suggest you do a minimal viable one
that has the primary components you need
and then migrate and then
add what you need afterwards.
Okay, 7Rs, okay yeah.
This is the simple 7Rs.
I'm gonna go through this
quickly, like I said,
because I feel like I'm
beating a dead horse with this,
but I wrote it so you're
gonna listen to it.
So what are the 7Rs?
Can anyone even name three of these?
I mean, I can't, so I won't raise my hand.
They all start with R though.
See, that makes it extra confusing.
So I'm gonna break 'em down.
So repurchase means that
we're not migrating,
we're replacing with SaaS, okay?
Retain means that we're
not migrating, right?
It means we're keeping
it on premises, okay.
Retire means we're just gonna shut it off.
So we're not migrating that.
Okay, so that's outta scope by definition.
So these three Rs do not
represent migration strategies.
They represent decisions not to migrate.
It's funny, I was talking to
an LLM about this the other day
and what was the joke?
It's like deciding where not to go
on vacation or something like that.
But yeah, they don't help us.
Now they might be useful
portfolio management strategies.
They certainly are, but
they don't have anything
to do with refactoring
and migration, right?
So they don't need to be made upfront.
We can make these decisions incrementally
or we can just not, these decisions
have nothing to do with
refactoring anyway.
Now, if we talk about the
things that are refactoring,
we have a couple choices
and neither of 'em, none of
them are really good, right?
So we have a full migration.
Refactor in the 7Rs language
means we're gonna change
the entire application.
This is a mainframe, right?
So I'd say that's like the
one of the very few examples
where you really have to do that.
But otherwise it's kind of a bad idea.
That's a lot of changes to
make while you're migrating,
a lot of things that could go wrong.
You could do it afterwards
and do it with all the tools in the cloud.
Then you have replatform,
which is a partial refactor, okay.
Rehost, which is no refactor,
known as a lift and shift.
And then this really oddball one relocate,
I think this was maybe
the most recent one.
I guess they wanted another R.
It's also a no refactor,
but from hypervisor like VMware, right?
The thing is, people could say,
"Well, those two are different."
But it doesn't represent a choice.
You don't get to choose
whether the application
is on hypervisor or not
or if it's physical.
So it's not a choice, so you
don't need another R for it.
So if remove the Rs that have
nothing to do with migration
and remove the redundant R, right?
We have three Rs left,
you see now, and we have a 3Rs model.
We've already simplified this.
But if you look at this,
something becomes very clear.
These 3Rs are nothing, they're not useful.
One is like a complete extreme refactor,
which you know you can do if you have to,
but otherwise it's probably a bad idea.
But it's a valid choice
if you want to do it.
You have a rehost, right?
A lift and shift, which
really doesn't exist
because you're not moving
your server to the cloud.
Migrate is a misnomer, right?
You're gonna rebuild it.
There's gonna be some
changes that are necessary.
And then you have well, replatform,
which is something, right?
Some amount of refactoring.
So what we find is that
there's not seven Rs.
It's really a spectrum, right?
It's an infinite spectrum of
how much refactoring we do.
Why are we choosing
these arbitrary buckets?
In fact, these buckets
don't help us at all, right?
We have rehost on one side,
refactor on the other,
which are very small edge
cases, if we think about it,
and then we have this
giant thing in the middle
called replatform, which doesn't give us
any meaningful guidance on what to do.
It just says we're
gonna make some changes,
but it doesn't say what
we're gonna change.
So it's really a 1R model,
we're gonna do something.
And yeah, I think a 1R model is good,
but I'm gonna rename it and call it MVR,
minimal viable refactoring.
Again, my favorite minimal viable thing
in this presentation.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
the right amount of refactoring
to achieve our goal.
And we're gonna do it as we migrate.
So we're gonna do it iteratively.
This is gonna be flexible,
fast, simple, and safe
by doing it this way.
So we're gonna start
with a lift and shift,
conceptually, right?
We're gonna say, if we took this server
and we just rebuilt it exactly
how it is today in the cloud,
what would it look like?
And then we're gonna
realize that's not optimal.
So, 'cause some of the
things are gonna get worse,
so we're gonna do what I call
the hippocratic oath of IT.
First, do no harm, right?
We're gonna say for security, compliance,
reliability, performance, and cost,
we're gonna do just enough refactoring
to make those things
not worse, but no more.
And then we're gonna save
the rest of the refactoring
for after we're in the cloud,
because it's just so much
easier to do it then.
And we want to get this
migration thing done quickly,
'cause the migration is kind
of, it should be a non-event.
It shouldn't be this long drawn out thing.
The key is to get to the
cloud as quickly as possible
and do your refactoring in the cloud.
Okay, so now here's the
really animated last slide.
Well second to last slide,
what it looks like in practice.
And so what I mean by loosely
coupled, non-blocking.
Okay, here's our applications.
It goes in two stages.
So first stage is it goes, it gets scoped.
So a project manager
identifies the app owner,
QA tester, the infrastructure,
the dependencies,
all those other things
that we talked about.
They document it.
Cloud engineer takes the application
and designs cloud architecture for it,
which will be really easy
'cause we're gonna make it
very similar to what we have on prem.
It gets approved by the
application owner or stakeholder.
It gets built by the cloud engineer,
hopefully using infrastructure as code,
but that's optional.
At the same time you start
transferring the data.
So it's being built while
the data's being transferred.
When both of those things are done,
the app owner gets to do
their pre-cutover testing
and approve it, or not approve it
and say they approve it, you
cut it over and it goes live.
Now we've gotta take
all of our applications
and we gotta put it through
this process, right?
So this is the one thing I
needed help from the agency
to help with the animation here.
All right, so our monitoring
application gets scoped
while, well, it gets moved
to architecture design
while email gets scoped.
And you can see kind of how things move
through this pipeline.
Now, this is very simple
when nothing's blocked,
but as soon as, you know
something's gonna get blocked,
'cause it always does, right?
Let's say, okay, approval,
we're always get blocked
looking for approval, right?
This is very common.
The guy's on vacation or just
doesn't wanna approve it.
Doesn't like it.
So what are we gonna do?
Normally what ends up happening here
is the whole thing comes to a halt
and web, email and
monitoring will go live,
and then everything else waits.
But we're good engineers, we
realize there's five places
where things could get blocked,
and we're just gonna put a queue on there
and let things queue up.
So then we route around the problem.
Hey, file servers can
stay stuck in that queue
for as long as it we want
while payroll application gets moved.
And so everything goes
through the process.
We keep routing around the problem.
This is a simplified version of it.
In reality, there's gonna be things
queuing up all over the place.
The key is we want things to
move through this pipeline
as quickly as possible.
Eventually the, whatever
it is gets unblocked,
gets sequenced back in, and then
you move it through this
process until you're done.
This is basically how you can architect
the mechanics of a migration in a way
that can be done very quickly,
and the key is you're
not waiting on anyone.
Nobody's just sitting doing nothing.
So just the principles as a recap
and then hopefully we can
take a couple questions.
So if you haven't found this out by now,
I'm a fan of going fast.
Go slow enough to figure
out what you want to do
and then go fast.
You get your migration done quickly.
It should be non-event,
get to the fun stuff.
Simplicity is how you're
gonna do it primarily.
Simplicity increases
speed and de-risks things
and it makes things less expensive.
You've heard of the migration
double bubble, right?
Well, I didn't have one
because my migration
was so, so quick, right?
And so the more you draw it out,
the more you're double paying.
So make it fast.
Use constraints to force innovation,
not just drive it and focus.
Invest in your people
because that is gonna be
the make it or break it detail.
If there's any one,
that's the biggest one.
Momentum is the KPI.
So if I talk to a customer
who's doing cloud migration,
that's what I'm looking
for to determine, predict,
whether they're gonna
be successful or not.
Are they going faster?
Are they going slower?
It's momentum, is it
speeding up or slowing down?
Doing always beats planning.
A little bit of planning is good,
but I've yet to see a migration
fail from lack of planning.
I see migrations fail from too
much planning all the time.
It's counterintuitive,
but people love planning when
they don't want to do the work
or they're unsure.
Migrate, then modernize.
Again, I'm not saying don't modernize.
Definitely modernize it's the
whole reason for migrating.
Just decouple them so they're
both simpler and less risky.
And finally, anybody can do this,
but only if they want to do it.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)